[Música]
ebrahim raisi asume el mando de iran
frente a numerosos retos entre ellos las
renegociaciones del acuerdo nuclear y
los problemas de desabastecimiento de
luz y agua y la profunda crisis
económica y del sistema de salud de los
que responsabilizan las sanciones
impuestas por eeuu deben levantarse las
sanciones contra irán apoyaremos
cualquier plan democrático que apoye
este objetivo la política de presión y
sanciones no hará que la nación de irán
dé marcha atrás en el seguimiento de sus
derechos legales en 2018 eeuu re impuso
sanciones a irán tras retirarse del
pacto nuclear que firmó junto a otras
potencias en 2015 en respuesta irán dejó
de cumplir con varios compromisos como
limitar el enriquecimiento de uranio
necesario para crear armamento nuclear
el pacto establecía que podría
enriquecerlo en un 3.67 por ciento y
actualmente está en un 60 por ciento lo
que preocupa a la comunidad
internacional instamos a irán a que
regrese pronto a las negociaciones para
que podamos tratar de concluir nuestro
trabajo
he escuchado lo que el nuevo presidente
iraní ha dicho al respecto de las
renegociaciones en viena no han logrado
un consenso hasta ahora